myriam qui est arrivé la rédactrice en
chef de public qui va nous montrer dans
un instant là une gt comment enfin alors
le procès de johnny qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ça myriam au procès de johnny et
oui qu'est-ce que vous êtes depuis
quelques jours ici vous prépare un peu
plus fort et j'ai pas vous avez un cold
wave non non c'est non non j'ai depuis
quelques jours dans sur les chaînes on
entend on a retrouvé un nouveau
testament mais c'est une perte de temps
tout le monde sait que ce qui compte
c'est le dernier qui a été fait
exactement son de la mousse
voilà ça ramait résumant fair75 à tous
les autres différences et le dernier
rédigé qui compte donc ça c'est un non
sens et il ya une info trop important
c'est qu'en fait de terrain juridique va
se déplacer où ils ont montré la carte
verte de johnny donc johnny est un
citoyen américain
donc le seul la seule le seul combat
possible pour les héritiers qui ont peut
être connu c'est bien sûr de dépasser le
combat sur ce thème là est ce que oui ou
non johnny vite en amérique
alors donc aujourd'hui avait le procès
donc tout le monde en parle encore je
vous le dis ça est encore un rien
derrière le mans alors lowrie david qui
réclame devant le tribunal un droit de
regard sur l'album posthume
il vient de sortir de johnny est ce que
vous aimez ou est ce que vous n'aimez
pas dites nous la vérité et rien vous
allez me donner des infos sur ce qui
s'est passé tout à l'heure vous vous
aimez moi j'aime je suis passionné
c'était sur les chaînes info j'ai
regardé tous l'autre est ce que vous
comprenez vous avez compris la question
laura et david qui demandent des bien
sûr et ils ont gagné aujourd'hui parce
que opaque et non laissez moi je vous
dis ils ont gagné parce que ça a été
reportée mais c'était pas évident que ce
soit reporté c'est eux qui avaient
demandé le référé le juge leur a donné
raison
parce que c'est vrai que sur le trust de
johnny plein d'incertitudes et le clan
laetitia n'avaient pas donné les docks
escales trust alors mais rien alors un
très sain une entité juridique qui peut
être représenté par des personnes
physiques ou des sociétés et en fait il
ya toute une ambiguïté là dessus parce
qu'on ne sait pas exactement qui est à
la tête de ceux de ce trust est en fait
ce trust a été décidé et c'est ça qui
est quand même important lors d'une lors
de la rédaction du testament en juillet
et depuis ce moment-là le patrimoine de
johnny est géré par ce trust dont vous
vous n'aimez pas belle et maintenant
j'aime pas et ont l'air très honnêtement
breaking news toute la journée pour voir
quoi personne parce qu'en fait ils
n'étaient pas là évidemment les
protagonistes seuls les avocats avec une
nuée de photographes et une nuée de
journalistes qui savait très bien que
comme neuf fois sur dix les reports sont
acceptés on ne saurait rien
donc tout ça pour rien ça fait pschitt
total franchement myriam ont résumé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais en gros
les avocats de laura et david ont
demandé un report parce qu'il n'avait
pas tous les éléments et notamment
l'élément qui se cache derrière ce
treuil ils ont fait quand même certaines
demandes à savoir un droit de regard sur
l'album posthume
tout ce qui va se poser en fait là comme
question c'est est-ce que johnny a
décidé de tous les titres qui ont été
faits avant sa mort où est-ce que des
choses ont été faites après treize mois
c'est pour ça qu'ils demandent un droit
de regard sur l'album posthume
ils ont également demandé à ce que les
le patrimoine financier soit soit gelée
et puis également d'un que les droits en
nouveau l'instant ça devient de nouveau
très vite vous n'aimez près non j'aime
parce que laura et david réclament leur
part du gâteau financier je conçois très
bien voilà je suis papou mais qu'ils le
fassent très bien en revanche le droit
de regard sur l'album posthume
jusqu'à preuve du contraire laetitia pas
décidé de faire un remix avec la
compagnie créole de l'album de johnny
donc voilà il ya pas grand risque quand
même sur l'album de johnny faut arrêter
tout va très vite philippe rejoindre
juste sur un plan juridique je vais
juste un tout petit peu contredire
malheureusement aux benjamins la carte
verte dont on vient de parler benjamin
ne fait pas de toi un citoyen américain
j'en mets de la vie à la carte verte
résident permanent doit de travailler au
rayonnement de l'héritère différents or
la vraie question de l'ensemble de ce
procès c'est doit-on appliquer le droit
américain où doit être appliqué le droit
foncier tout ça donc voilà qu'est-ce qui
distribue zaramo juste un mot sur le
trust est très important c'est
typiquement américain c'est à moyenne
c'est un excellent moyen d'évasion
fiscale et de plus c'est parfaitement
légal pour déshériter ses enfants donc
c'est un mauvais coup c'est totalement
légale et en plus si si jamie s'avère
que ben voilà l'ailé laura et david
peuvent toucher l'héritage ça a posé des
problèmes aux sites fiscalité française
le fils très bien voilà demandé l'état
demandé des droits fiscaux et pour le
coup ça fera du mal à tous